entonces quiso las declaraciones del
presidente de manuel macrón avivaron el
incendio que se ha generado en la
asamblea nacional en una entrevista
publicada por el diario le parisien el
mandatario francés dijo que arremeter
contra las personas que no estén
vacunadas contra el cob y 19 en francia
las medidas más drásticas prohibirles la
entrada a lugares públicos
tras las declaraciones la asamblea
nacional volvió a suspender en la noche
del martes el debate sobre el proyecto
de ley que contempla la introducción de
un pase de vacunación
por mi parte estoy a favor del fase de
vacunación pero no puedo respaldar un
texto que pretende arremeter contra los
franceses entonces señor ministro de
acuerdo con la voluntad del presidente
de la república busque aparece ante
nosotros nos presenta este texto con el
único objetivo de molestar a los
franceses es es su voluntad si o no
debemos tener una respuesta no podemos
seguir discutiendo sin que haya
respondido con precisión a esta pregunta
por su parte el ministro de salud
respondió
todos conocemos aquí y nadie lo puede
negar sin excepción el mal hoy azota a
nuestro país ante una pandemia que
circula con fuerza es una vacuna que
aunque importante sigue siendo
insuficiente con millones de nuestros
compatriotas que todavía se niegan a
vacunar digo si es este ahora exhibe
en 2021 o francia implementó un pase
sanitario que obliga a que las personas
muestren una prueba pcr negativa de kobe
19 o el carnet de vacunación para poder
ingresar a lugares públicos pero ahora
el gobierno está haciendo lo posible por
convertirlo en un pase de vacunación así
solo los vacunados podrán ingresar a
todos los lugares sin restricción la
asamblea nacional sigue debatiendo el
proyecto de ley que de aprobarse
entraría en vigor a partir del 15 de
enero la propuesta del gobierno llega en
un momento en el que la variante omicron
de el coronavirus ha elevado los
contagios diarios en francia el martes
el país confirmó 271 mil 686 casos una
cifra récord